[Music]
south africa has more coronavirus cases
than
any other country in africa with almost
640 thousand cases reported there
south african students started returning
to school weeks ago
but it's become a very huge challenge
for them as deborah potter shows us
many have had to adapt to a whole new
way of doing things
south africa is a deeply unequal society
which means during its hard lockdown
thousands of children like these had no
learning at all because of a lack of
access to technology
forcing educators to come up with
creative solutions
online learning is all very well if
there is good internet in your
neighborhood
but if you live in a poor township and
don't even have electricity
it's impossible so for many students in
south africa
going back to school was the only
solution access to resources may differ
from school to school
but protocols are the same temperature
checks
masks hand sanitization and social
distancing
dendron secondary school in an
impoverished rural area took it one step
further
every child here in this classroom knows
that an education is their only ticket
to a better future
and they were not going to let a
pandemic stand in the way of that
while other children were playing during
south africa's hard lockdown
these final year students moved in with
their teachers
who supervise their studies in small
home groups
there are four four people in each room
and we get lunch there after school
kopano le palala is dendron's top
performing student
it's important because getting a good
education especially in south africa
it sort of like determines where you're
going to end up in life
so you need to get a good education so
you can get into a good
university or even just become some
someone better
as yourself to make up for
any lost time these students are now at
school every day from
seven in the morning until nine at night
seven days a week
is teaching a larger lesson in life
there's no excuse
there is no certificate that will be
written covet
i believe that nothing beats the human
spirit
an elite all girls school in
johannesburg
access to technology has made the
physical challenges posed by the
pandemic
easier to manage the younger grades
rotate
between in-person and online learning so
that strict
social distancing can be maintained in
classrooms
to accommodate only 15 students at a
time
but there are still emotional concerns
for some of the girls being isolated not
being able to spend time with their
friends
was really really difficult we had quite
a number of parents phoning and saying
my daughter's for the first time in her
life she's experiencing anxiety or
depression
the school psychologists have been
offering counseling services
but for the most part south african
scholars have adapted quickly to
schooling
in a covered world
at the beginning of this pandemic there
were infection outbreaks in some schools
but since health protocols have been
adopted nationwide
most schools are managing to keep their
children safe from covert
for cbs this morning deborah patter
johannesburg
thanks deborah we're all trying to keep
up with all of this that's going on i
think sometimes a lot of people forget
the impact that it has on children and
it's good to have the ipads and
computers but it doesn't matter if you
don't have wi-fi like some of them don't
have in those townships
they so value education and then what it
means to be able to socialize with your
friends
is so important and as she pointed out
isolation for some kids is
it's is way more impactful than others
yes
we're adults too anthony absolutely i
think the psychological impact of this
has yet to be
is really yet to be fully measured i
wonder what american teachers are
thinking is they see students moving in
to get the work done yeah yeah new
meaning to the term boarding school
yes